I'm sorry sorry I'm sorry
I get I get so excited about medieval
engineering because I'm a 5-game so I
actually used to study engineering so I
know a thing or two about Vikings some
Swedish yes ah yes here we are
am I wearing like a bowl on my head
the Swedish Viking Torvald
I can sit I can jump I can I can fly Wow
so this is medieval engineers we can
build blocks Wow Wow
oh [ __ ] but I should have died but I'm a
Viking so I'd won
there we go that's my tower that's no
what happened
that's my tower see it works fine oh
[ __ ] come on not tape it did I forget to
the glue again god f just build just
it's stable it's stable holy [ __ ] it's
stable oh [ __ ] nevermind tape it tape it
oh god oh god oh god no all right oh oh
come on how catalysis will you break no
you want will you break oh my god what
are we building here
I built a giant p4p NAT PewDiePie
PewDiePie let's go - you know what let's
go to the mountains and build the
greatest Tower this land has ever known
here yes yes beautiful no no you're
going too high man this is this is
[ __ ] you're this stop breaking god
dammit
are you kidding me right now
I am a shitty engineer how about that oh
you know not to pee not the pain
what how did you even break look at that
oh I made a green ball bra oh damn I can
Rick [ __ ] too
I mean that's all I've been doing but
[ __ ] it yay take that stupid stupid
plastic village
oh you hold that [ __ ] but not me
building you
let's build what every Viking village
ever is missing
you guessed that a McDonald's and why
wasn't why was there no McDonald's in
the medieval age you might ask that's
because I wasn't born yet
that's because I the greatest architect
the universe was not there to invent it
they told me I couldn't build the
medieval McDonald's but they were wrong
I never I never seen art in such a
profound way until I played Viking
McDonald's simulator 2015 do you feel
the same way do you feel the love that
I'm feeling right now this is so
beautiful I want to cry I wanna I'm
gonna cry
manly Viking tears of course look at
that McDonald's this is the greatest
McDonald's this land of seven own we
have to make sure though that it passes
the security measurements otherwise
we'll get sued yeah that's fine that's
the standard issue
all right let's launch inside it as well
she said shut up all right
hey it passed the test it passed the
test of McDonald's now we will be rich
man we're gonna be so [ __ ] rich bros
do you have no idea yes
that's an M that's an M for McDonald's
do you see it that's an M right there
McDonald's
welcome home kids it's my tower breaking
I don't think so
it's holding it's holding oh oh god
dammit how does that work how does that
work I'd this one break right nailed it
nailed nailed it ah now here oh look I
built this castle Oh all by myself
enter my build what are you doing what
and turn you idiot oh my god I'm
building grass towers this is [ __ ]
amazing this will be the greatest grass
penis this land has ever known look at
it it's magnificent so green and hairy
oh yay oh my god this is so laggy
someone actually built from The Hobbit
Erebor it's always cold but I wish it
was in this laggy but that's pretty cool
can we go inside
oh my [ __ ] god that's ah oh my god
damn this game has only been out for
like what a few few days oh god don't
fall off that's [ __ ] awesome call I'm
never ever ever gonna spend anywhere
near enough time to build anything like
that but that's it's cool here we go
parkour baby Wow oh yeah brah 360 Wow
yeah oh god grind it grind that [ __ ] G
oh god it's lagging hello what happened
I mean uh what are you doing
hope you enjoyed this first episode of
medieval engineers leave me your
suggestions what you want me to build in
the description how would you do that I
have no idea I'm at the comments I'm
sorry
all right price stay awesome margarines
shut up you son of a [ __ ] a pocket
Calliope aired dude dude don't worry
she's fine she's fine